truth
is realizing that this
is infinity appearing
the realization
of you are
source
i am infinity
this reality is an appearance
of infinity expressing itself
that is truth realization
this is what is meant across all of the
perennial
wisdoms across the
millennia of mystic traditions
mysticism means union
that is what yoga means in sanskrit
the greeks called it hypnosis
it means becoming one with
god with the infinite
with source
with brahman with
dao
our very home
has no attributes
our very home has no agent
it is metaphysical zero
and yet our home
is also this
appearance
therefore our home is both the very fact
that we have no name
slash form and yet it is also
the very fact that we have an infinite
possibility of name and form
of which this dreamed creation
is but one expression of
that
i am source expressing itself
this appearance is one
example of name and form
this specific civilization
secreted on this planet earth orbiting
this star with this specific
historical lineage that has led to this
live stream
how many different combinations of name
and form can you imagine
if the answer is endless then you've
truth
realized
how many different combinations of
musical notes
can be put into a song
infinite
how many combinations
of paint can you put on a canvas
infinite
form and name appearing
endlessly creatively
anarchically eternal exploration
that is this that is our true nature
that is metaphysical truth
simply come to your source
your very infinitude and you become
truth realized
in your profound revelations
will be woven like the tantric
path indicates into
the dreamed creation design
you are already the fish in the ocean
you are already in union with infinity
you are already in union with source
therefore truth can't be realized
because you already are it
yet it remains for you to recognize
it you are going from room to
room looking for the diamond necklace
that is already
around your neck as rumi said
therefore truth can be realized
a contracted identity of being a
separate egoic entity
relaxes it dissolves
it expands back into its very oceanic
infinitude
the separate self egoic contracted fish
that does not know its true nature
recognizes its true nature
truth realizes itself as
source as swimming in oceanic
infinitude and that being its home
as well as its unique expression
of a fish
you are both source slash
infinity as well as the
unique expression of source slash
infinity in this dream creation design
your form and name and layers of
identity
are both something for you to completely
shed to truth realize yourself as
source infinity and yet it is also your
unique firework
you are bringing a unique individuated
contributory gift into civilization
do not discredit this
this is the beautiful way that
infinity slash source expresses itself
the west is not wrong
by applauding the individual
it is a synthesis between the
non-duality
of the east as well as the individuation
of the west
as sri aurobindo and the mother meera
alfasa
said diversity in oneness
is the mathematics of
the infinite truth realization
is your ability to simultaneously
hold the non-dual
perfection with
the dual perfecting
to accelerate the dualistic
perfecting away from ignorance
and towards knowledge towards liberation
towards eradicating of suffering and
maximizing
planetary well-being
one has to elevate
their ability to parse for
signal in the oceanic
noise
mass media
gluttony polarization
propaganda
none of those serve you
learn to fast from
that input
that oceanic noise keeps
you asleep
hypnotized
parsing for the signal is parsing for
higher vibrations for higher
frequency for truth realization
of oneself as infinity as
source expressing itself
many people begin parsing for signal
through self-actualization literature
tony robbins gary vaynerchuk
jordan peterson
incredible stuff very empowerment driven
it's great and then
you become even more subtle and you
direct
the empowerment towards enlightenment
towards self-realization and that's when
you pick up ramana maharshi
that's when you pick up nisargata
maharaja
that's when you pick up rupert spyra
bentino massaro
lao tza the dao de jing the old and new
testament
zocchen theravada buddhism
entheogens
that self-realization enlightenment
and liberation recognition of oneself as
infinity as source
gets woven into a beautiful
lattice work along with all of the self
actualization the efficiencies and
optimizations in the outward expression
including science and engineering and
art
and the digital quotient and the
emotional quotient
are woven into this beautiful conceptual
lattice work
that is what wadat al-wujud the sufi
metaphysic the unity of all unveiling
and finding means
you have a unique style of piercing
the veilless veil optimize your signal
over noise parsing
algorithm
weave more and more of the profound
things that the geniuses
that have lived and died before you have
uncovered into your lattice work
that will then accelerate your ability
to pierce that veilus veil and have your
own unique
style of finding yourself to be
infinity to be source expressing itself
as this unique
firework
you are both what has no name
and no form the metaphysical zero
agentless attributeless
infinitely expressing itself
as eternal fireworks like francis
lucille said
outward in these dreamed creation
designs where you take on
infinite amounts of name and form
and that is what this is that is what we
are infinity
appearing that is the truth realization
so the pause of the metaphysical zero
is both home and
it's impossible because there is
only the eternal journey
as much as you want like in the parable
of the prodigal son
that absolute gps callback
for you to realize yourself as
infinity source expressing itself
the eternal journey continues
the journey of infinity expressing
itself
endlessly continues you will continue
being both the no name
and no form of metaphysical zero
like you will simultaneously continue
being
infinite name and infinite form
in these unique firework expressions
and that is why sri aurobindo and the
mother meera alfasa
said becoming is the only
being that is why
parmenidus spent
his realization on
how all appearance is merely an illusion
and that
being that metaphysical zero is ultimate
meanwhile heraclitus very much the yin
and yang
two thousand five hundred years ago in
greece said ponte rey
everything flows no man will ever step
in the same river twice
and that is how you synthesize the two
into one
very much a non-dual
metaphysical zero that is already
perfect while it is expressed
as a dualistic
individual where there
is a perfecting
that is happening of those
individuations as they
realize themselves as infinity source
and as they express their uniqueness
outward
that is the truth realization
true simultaneity
infinity appearing
the no name slash form
and the infinite name slash form
simultaneously
you are already that non-dual perfection
and yet it remains for you to recognize
it
for you to increase your parsing
of signal
for you to draw more and more of the
profound
realizations from the disciplines into a
beautiful conceptual lattice work
that then is your unique style
of finding
recognize this truth realization
and feel the
home of peace
of happiness
and of awe
at our own true nature
infinitely expressing itself
thank you
you